[Music]
kendra is in dayton ohio hi kendra how
are you
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
okay baby step six um we have
a house that's worth around 400 we owe
250.
um we are at a 22 year fixed we couldn't
get it down to the 15 at this point we
have about 140 000 worth of repairs and
updates and things that we need to do
uh to sell we're looking to sell in
three to five years in downsize
so
i recently
got a better job so the shuttle's a
little bigger so i'm trying to figure
out
do we pay down the mortgage or do the
updates
uh what's your household income
it's around 200 now good
so if you do the up i mean if you if you
pay down the mortgage and you don't do
the updates how you gonna sell
um exactly yeah so i think you do the
updates what in the world is wrong with
this house 140 000 on a 400 000 house
falling in
uh
yes and no it has um
it's just some parts are dated and was
when we bought it
um but it just matched what we needed
for our family yeah but what's wrong i
mean what are you talking about doing
for a hundred and forty thousand dollars
yeah anyone type someone says repairs
and updates
that i always want to support those
apartments yeah
it's bowls it's bold because the kitchen
and bathrooms need updates and this is
per realtor coming in and saying okay
here are things i recommend in order to
get you know the best price for the
house kind of thing and within our
neighborhood
um
and so it's a deck where the wood is
literally falling through somebody fell
through the steps so
it's it's a
air conditioning unit that needs
replaced it's
roof it's windows
siding
um
those are more of the repair sides and
the updates the kitchens and the
bathrooms and flooring
wow
you guys have let this place run down to
nothing
we were doing the steps and that was the
struggle you just now got to babysit
four five six
uh yes okay cool yeah that's good only
within the last six months number one
separate the updates and repairs do the
repairs first
okay the deck that's falling is not
expensive number one number two it's
dangerous fix that
the heating area they quoted us out like
20 for that
20 000 dollars
yeah and that was there
it's large
and so that was one of the cheaper beds
okay well just try to figure out if
there's a different way to skin this cat
that sounds a little bit
you know there's that still sounds out
of control
the first one was 40.
okay
they all sound out of control
one of them sounds twice as much out of
control as the other one but still
it's wood and that is out of control
right now yeah okay well bottom line is
you need to you just need to segment
these items make a list and prioritize
them and begin the cash flow of them
through them number one item is most
dangerous number two is next most
dangerous then once you get past
dangerous stuff or leaking or repairs
and get over into updates maybe you do
some of the updates maybe you don't
maybe you just sell a house with an
outdated bathroom and
and that was that yeah exactly that's
very struggling or do we refinance no
you don't need the refinances
you're trying to get out of that we're
not trying to add right that was not one
of your questions right you make 200 you
have three to four years to do and forty
thousand dollars worth and so if you
divide that by three that's fifty
thousand a year um you can get it done
in three years and just make your list
out and just systematically begin to
work down the thing it's not all one
project at one
time correct and when i was talking
refinance i was talking about putting
money towards the principle to get it
down to the 15-year fix not borrowing
against it yeah well i i no need to pay
to refinance to do that you just pay
extra on the mortgage
but we're not you're not able to do that
till you get this stuff done whatever
you choose to do to get the house market
ready
whatever you choose to do the more you
study it the more you think about it and
the more you get bids on it
um and and by the way i'm you know i in
the next six months do as little of it
as you can
because let's give some of this
craziness time to some of the crazy to
bleed off
of the construction world
because the construction world's in
full-on crazy mode right now yes and so
let it you know let's not get in too big
a hurry
uh because lumber might come back down
matter of fact it probably will it's you
know once they start
bringing the trees out of the forest
again you know that kind of stuff it's
it's a supply demand issue
and so um
you know uh but but uh you know
the way you eat an elephant is a bite at
a time and that's how i would get at
this i want to i also want to make sure
over the next three to five years
i've made this mistake a couple times
dave
i have a goal that's three years away or
five years away so i'm gonna try to get
through a school program or something
like that
man
i i lose three years of life
because i don't like where i'm at i'm
always looking at what tomorrow's going
to be and so i want to balance that
140 000
we got to get
you're not going to get all these things
done and all of a sudden the sun's going
to come out this is going to come out
anyway so make your plan work towards
these things and then enjoy the house
while you're in it and sell it and sell
it at some point just sell it call it a
day yeah you know i'm done i'm out of
here